AND EVEN MORE GOOD NEWS ON THE
ECONOMY TONIGHT.
WE WILL HAVE ALL OF THIS AND
MORE.
BUCKLE UP, AN AMAZING NIGHT AND
OPENING NEWS MONOLOGUE.
THIS IS GREAT NEWS, THE DATE HAS
BEEN SET IN THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL MICHAEL
HOROWITZ ANTICIPATES THE RELEASE
OF HIS ALL-IMPORTANT REPORT,
THIS HAS GONE ON 18 MONTHS AND
THE DATA SET FOR NEXT THURSDAY,
ONE WEEK FROM TONIGHT.
FOR WEEKS WE HAVE BEEN
PREDICTING THAT THESE FINDINGS
WHAT EFFECT BE BURIED AND
RELEASED WHEN ALL EYES WOULD BE
FIXED ON THE PRESIDENT'S
HISTORIC MEETINGS IN SINGAPORE.
SADLY, I THINK MY PREDICTION WAS
SOMEWHAT RIGHT AND IT'S ONLY TWO
DAYS AFTER THIS BIG SUMMIT TAKES
PLACE.
AND THEN OF COURSE THIS WILL BE
RELEASED.
WHAT HAS THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
POTENTIALLY REDACTED OR CHANGED?
THEY'VE HAD IT FOR OVER TWO
WEEKS NOW, DID THEY ALTER ANY
LANGUAGE?
HOW WILL THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
WILL THEY GET THE TRUTH IN ALL
OF THIS?
WILL THEY BE PREVENTED FROM
SEEING THE TRUTH?
IN OTHER WORDS, ARE WE GOING TO
GET UNFETTERED CONTENTS OF
INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ'S
REPORT?
NEXT WEEK ON HANNITY WE WILL BE
ANALYZING THAT REPORT PAGE BY
PAGE ON WHAT WILL BE ONE OF THE
MOST CONSEQUENTIAL DAYS IN
MODERN HISTORY.
THAT IS TWO DAYS OF COURSE AFTER
THE SUMMIT.
SORRY, I AM SUSPICIOUS AND
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE    STAND COR
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE    STAND COE
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE    STAND COT
HOPEFULLY I WILL BE    STAND COD
NEXT WEEK.
ONE GOOD DEVELOPMENT TO REPORT,
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HOROWITZ
IS SET TO TESTIFY BEFORE THE
SENATE THE MONDAY FOLLOWING THE
THURSDAY RELEASE, AND OF COURSE
ALL OF THIS ON THE HEELS OF A
NONSTOP EFFORT THAT WE HAVE SEEN
BY CONGRESS, BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE TO CONGRESS TO
OBSTRUCT CONGRESS
CONSTITUTIONAL DUTY.
AND THAT HIS OVERSIGHT IN THEIR
INVESTIGATIONS.
ACCORDING TO SENATOR GRASSLEY'S
OFFICE, THE DOJ IS NOW REFUSING
TO MAKE DOCUMENTS AND AT LEAST
ONE WITNESS AVAILABLE FOR THEIR
OVERSIGHT INTO THE FBI'S ONGOING
GENERAL FLYNN INVESTIGATION.
ADD TO THIS THE DOJ CONSTANT
SLOW WALKING OF THOSE DOCUMENTS
TO ALL THE HOUSE COMMITTEE IS,
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE, THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE.
SARAH CARTER WILL TAKE DOWN I
CAN TELL YOU ALL ABOUT A HUGE
FIGHT EARLIER TODAY AND HOW THE
DOJ HAS RENEGED EARLIER THIS
MORNING ON A PREVIOUS COMMITMENT
TO SUPPLY DOCUMENTS THAT ARE
RELATED TO THE INVESTIGATION.
THE BIG BATTLE, IT ENDED UP THAT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE NOW
ADDED UNPRECEDENTED NEW RULES ON
HOW THEY PLAN TO BRIEF MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
WHAT WE NEED IS FOR YOU, THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE COME UP TO BE
ABLE TO SEE IT FOR YOURSELF.
YESTERDAY WE REPORTED ON HOW ROB
ROSENSTEIN ARROGANTLY REBUFFED
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM IN HIS
LETTER DEMANDING TO KNOW WHY THE
HEAD OF THE MUELLER IN THE
INVESTIGATION HAS NOT RENOUNCED
HIMSELF.
INCLUDING HIS KEY ROLE IN    IN
INCLUDING HIS KEY ROLE IN    INH
INCLUDING HIS KEY ROLE IN    INE
DECISION TO FIRE JAMES COMEY
PERIODS WITNESS NUMBER ONE IN
THAT CASE AND OF COURSE, HE WAS
THE PERSON THAT SIGNED OFF ON
THE THIRD SUBSEQUENT RENEWAL
APPLICATION AS IT RELATES TO THE
PFIZER WARRANT THAT OF COURSE
WAS SPYING ON A TRUMP CAMPAIGN
ASSOCIATE.
SENATOR GRAHAM IS RESPONDING.
>> ARE YOU SATISFIED WITH
WHETHER ROB ROSENSTEIN HAD BEEN
RECUSED?
>> NO.
YOU TALK ABOUT A
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AND I GET THAT.
THE QUESTION IS, THE OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE.
THEY NEED TO TAKE A SERIOUS LOOK
AS TO WHETHER OR NOT IT WAS AN
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE BY FIRING
HIM.
HE'S A FINE GUY AND I HAVE
NOTHING AGAINST HIM.
I THINK HE IS DOING A GOOD JOB.
I UNDERSTAND WHY JEFF SESSIONS
CAN'T DO THIS.
I'M REALLY CURIOUS AS TO HOW
ROSENSTEIN COULD BE INVOLVED IN
OVERSEEING THIS INVESTIGATION IF
HE'S GOING TO BE A WITNESS.
>> Sean: WE WILL HAVE MORE ON
THIS THROUGHOUT THE SHOW BUT,
FIRST WE HAVE AN AND EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BIT OF NEWS.
THE PRESIDENT'S HISTORIC
IMPENDING TRIP TO SINGAPORE JUST
DAYS AWAY FROM HOLDING THESE
TALKS WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
DICTATOR, KIM JONG UN.
THEY ARE GOING TO TALK ABOUT THE
COMPLETE AND TOTAL
DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE KOREAN
PENINSULA.
ALL OF THAT IS ON THE LINE.
EARLIER TODAY, THE PRESIDENT
GAVE A PREVIEW OF THE UPCOMING
TRIP.
>> President Trump: I HOPE THE
UPCOMING MEETING IN SINGAPORE
REPRESENTS THE BEGINNING OF A
BRIGHT NEW FUTURE FOR
NORTH KOREA, AND INDEED, A
BRIGHT NEW FUTURE FOR THE WORLD.
THE DENUCLEARIZATION OF THE
KOREAN PENINSULA WOULD USHER IN
A NEW ERA OF PROSPERITY,
SECURITY, AND PEACE FOR ALL
KOREANS, NORTH AND SOUTH.
AND FOR PEOPLE EVERYWHERE.
WE COULD ABSOLUTELY SIGN AN
AGREEMENT.
WE ARE LOOKING AT IT AND TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH THEM, TALKING
ABOUT IT WITH A LOT OF OTHER
PEOPLE.
THAT COULD HAPPEN, BUT THAT'S
REALLY THE BEGINNING.
IT SOUNDS A LITTLE BIT STRANGE
BUT THAT'S PROBABLY THE EASY
PART.
THE HARD PART REMAINS AFTER
THAT.
MAXIMUM PRESSURE IS ABSOLUTELY
INEFFECTIVE.
WE DON'T USE THE TERM ANYMORE
BECAUSE WE ARE GOING INTO A
FRIENDLY NEGOTIATION.
PERHAPS AFTER THAT NEGOTIATION,
I WILL BE USING IT AGAIN.
HE WILL KNOW HOW WELL WE DO IN
THE NEGOTIATION, IF YOU HEAR ME
SAYING WE ARE GOING TO USE A
MAXIMUM PRESSURE, THEN YOU KNOW
THE NEGOTIATION DID NOT GO WELL.
>> IF THE SUMMER DUMB ACTS ON GO
WELL WILL YOU INVITE KIM JONG UN
TO THE UNITED STATES?
SPEAK TO THE ANSWER IS YES TO
THE SECOND PART OF YOUR
QUESTION, CERTAINLY IF IT GOES
WELL.
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE WELL
RECEIVED AND I THINK HE WOULD
LOOK AT IT VERY FAVORABLY, SO I
THINK THAT COULD HAVE BEEN.
ALL I CAN SAY IS I'M TOTALLY
PREPARED TO WALK AWAY.
I DID IT ONCE BEFORE.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE TO WALK
AWAY.
I REALLY BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
THE POTENTIAL TO DO SOMETHING
INCREDIBLE FOR THE WORLD.
IT'S MY HONOR TO BE INVOLVED.
>> Sean: THE SECRETARY OF
STATE MIKE POMPEO HAS PAID     P
STATE MIKE POMPEO HAS PAID     A
STATE MIKE POMPEO HAS PAID     E
STATE MIKE POMPEO HAS PAID     D
STATE MIKE POMPEO HAS PAID     A
VERY IMPORTANT ROLE IN THESE
DISCUSSIONS THAT LEAD UP TO ALL
THIS AND HE WEIGHED IN ON THESE
UPCOMING TALKS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE FACT THAT OUR TWO LEADERS
ARE COMING TO THE TABLE SHOWS
THE TWO SIDES ARE VERY SERIOUS.
THE DIPLOMATIC MODEL WE USE
TODAY IS DIFFERENT FROM PAST
EFFORTS.
OUR EFFORTS GIVE US HOPE THAT WE
CAN FIND REAL SUCCESS WHERE PAST
EFFORTS HAVE FALLEN SHORT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS HOPEFUL.
BUT, HE'S ALSO GOING INTO THE
SUMMIT WITH HIS EYES WIDE OPEN.
WE HAVE SEEN HOW MANY INADEQUATE
AGREEMENTS HAVE BEEN STUCK IN
THE PAST.
YOU CAN BE SURE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL NOT STAND
FOR A BAD DEAL.
>> Sean: HERE WE ARE ONLY DAYS
AWAY FROM DIPLOMATIC PROGRESS.
THE FORMER PRESIDENT OBAMA
FRANKLY ONLY DREAMED OF AND THE
MAJORITY OF AMERICANS, ARE
RESPONDING OVERWHELMINGLY NOW
SUPPORTING THE PRESIDENT'S
UPCOMING SUMMIT.
ALL OF THIS AFTER THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA DOUBTED.
THERE WAS FEARMONGERING, TALKS
OF NUCLEAR WAR, AND IN A SAD
WAY, I THINK MANY, BECAUSE I
DON'T LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
THEY WANT THE DEMOCRATS TO WIN,
ACTUALLY ROOTING AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT SUCCESS HERE.
THAT'S NOT FOR THE COUNTRY.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> THE IDEA OF A NUCLEAR
SHOWDOWN WITH NORTH KOREA KEEPS
YOU UP AT NIGHT, I'D RECOMMEND
DELETING YOUR TWITTER APP.
>> IS NOT BEING CAVALIER ABOUT
NUCLEAR WAR COMPANIES BEING
CAVALIER IN A WAY THAT MAKES HIM
SEEM DEMENTED.
>> THESE ARE MESSAGES FROM A
LEADER WHO IS NOT FIT FOR
OFFICE.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP IS GOADING
KIM JONG UN TO TEST A NUCLEAR
MISSILE AGAIN, TO PROVE ITS
RELIABILITY, TO SHOW HIM WRONG.
AND FUNDAMENTALLY, I THINK IT
COMES ACROSS AS TO
KINDERGARTNERS WHO ARE JOSTLING
EACH OTHER, EXCEPT EACH HAS
NUCLEAR WEAPONS.
>> IT WAS TOO LATE, AFTER
100,000 AMERICANS DIED.
FOR AFTER A MILLION DIED.
>> AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE, THIS
IS NOT AN EXAGGERATION.
>> Sean: TRUMPS COMMENTS ABOUT
NUCLEAR WEAPONS HAVE EXPERTS
WORRY THAT HE COULD
INADVERTENTLY TRIGGER A
CATASTROPHE.
TYPICAL CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THESE NUCLEAR TEST SO FAR, LET'S
GO THROUGH THIS.
NO MORE MISSILES FIRED OVER
JAPAN, GUAM IS NOT BEING
THREATENED AND ROUTE THE REGION
IS NOT BEING THREATENED.
WE DO HAVE THREE AMERICAN
HOSTAGES, THANK GOD THEY ARE
HOME AND HAVE BEEN FREED.
WHAT YOU SAW WAS JUST FAKE NEWS,
WE WATCHED KIM JONG UN WALK
ACROSS THE DMZ RIGHT INTO THE
ARMS OF THE SOUTH KOREAN
PRESIDENT, AND THE DISMANTLING
OF ONE OF HIS NUCLEAR TEST
SITES.
BECAUSE THIS IS 1 OF 3 EGREGIOUS
EXAMPLES OF FAKE NEWS THAT WE
ARE HIGHLIGHTING TONIGHT.
HERE'S NUMBER TWO.
OVER THERE, CONSPIRACY TV,
MSNBC, THERE YOU GO.
THEY CAN'T HELP THEMSELVES.
USUALLY MIKA SPENCER MORNING
PUSHING THEORIES ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTS MENTAL HEALTH WITH OF
COURSE JOE SCARBOROUGH, WHO IS
THE LIBERAL.
BUT TODAY SHE VENTURED OUT ON
HER OWN AND FLOATED THIS INSANE
RUMOR.
>> I WILL TELL YOU A COUPLE OF
THINGS.
FIRST OF ALL, THE HYPOCRISY IS
ASTOUNDING BECAUSE I KNOW
SOMEONE WHO SPOKE TO
DONALD TRUMP RECENTLY ABOUT LIFE
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, AND IT
DONALD TRUMP'S BIGGEST COMPLAINT
WAS THAT HE IS NOT ALLOWED TO
WATCH IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> I BET THEY HAVE THOSE 1900
NUMBERS BLOCKED, TOO.
>> I'M NOT REALLY SURE.
>> Sean: ARE YOU PROUD OF
THAT?
DOES THIS IS WHAT IS SO CALLED
NEWS OVER THERE AT 30 ROCK?
THIS IS SO INSANE, HONESTLY, I
CAN'T EVEN BOTHER.
LET'S GO TO OUR THIRD.
YESTERDAY ON MY RADIO SHOW, I
MADE WHAT ARE OBVIOUSLY
SARCASTIC REMARKS HIGHLIGHTING A
CLEAR DOUBLE STANDARD AS IT
RELATES TO OUR JUSTICE SYSTEM.
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW,
EQUAL APPLICATION OF OUR
NATION'S LAW.
LAWS, AND I WAS TALKING ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON AND COMPARING
HURTS TO WHAT SHE DID FOR THOSE
THAT HAVE BEEN TARGETED BY
MUELLER'S WITCH HUNT.
>> MAYBE MUELLER'S WITNESSES, I
DON'T KNOW.
IF I ADVISED THEM TO DELETE ALL
OF YOUR EMAILS AND THEN ASKED TO
WASH THE EMAILS ON YOUR HARD
DRIVES AND PHONES, THEN TAKE
YOUR PHONES AND BASH THEM WITH A
HAMMER, USE BLEACH BIT, TAKE THE
SAME CARD, THEN HAND THE PIECES
TO ROBERT MUELLER AND SAY, AND
HILLARY RODHAM CLINTON, THIS IS
EQUAL JUSTICE UNDER THE LAW.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT WOULD
WORK?
I'M CERTAIN THE RESULT WOULD NOT
BE THE SAME AS HILLARY'S.
MUELLER WANTS EVERYONE
CELL PHONES.
MY ADVICE TO HIM WOULD BE, NOT
REALLY, I'M KIDDING, BAD ADVICE.
FOLLOW HILLARY'S LEADER.
>> Sean: I SAID IT, IF WORDS
ACTUALLY MATTERED.
IF I TOLD THEM.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, THE INSANE
LEFT-WING MEDIA IN THIS COUNTRY,
HEADLINE AFTER HEADLINE.
THEY PICKED UP THESE COMMENTS.
THEY ARE SO DUMB AND GULLIBLE.
THEY HAD A FULL ON, I CAN ONLY
DESCRIBE AS A FAKE NEWS FREAK
OUT.
LOOK AT "NEWSWEEK,"
SEAN HANNITY'S ADVICE TO COMEY'S
WITNESSES, BASHORE HOME WITH THE
NONACADEMIC PHONE WITH A HAMMER.
FROM THE BUSINESS INSIDER,
SEAN HANNITY SUGGESTS THAT COMEY
PROBE WITNESSES SHOULD DESTROY
THEIR EVIDENCE.
AND MORE FAKE NEWS FROM THE
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEA
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAA
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAN
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAT
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEA
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAR
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAA
DAILY COST, CHANNEL         SEAS
THE LAW ON TV TELLING WITNESSES
TO DESTROY EVIDENCE.
AND "VANITY FAIR," SEAN HANNITY:
TRUMP ASSOCIATES, YOU ARE NOT
OBSTRUCTING JUSTICE HARD ENOUGH.
BASHORE PHONES INTO PIECES.
"GQ" GOT INTO THE GAME.
SEAN HANNITY ENCOURAGES COMEY
WITNESSES TO DO EVEN MORE CRIMES
THAN THEY HAVE ALREADY
COMMITTED.
I COULD GO ON FOR ANOTHER
20 MINUTES.
BUT THEN THAT HYSTERIA GETS EVEN
WORSE.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT HOW ANDY
LACK'S NETWORK HANDLE THIS.
>> SEAN HANNITY IS NOW TELLING
POTENTIAL WITNESSES AND SUBJECTS
IN THE COMEY PROBE TO DESTROY --
MUELLER PROBE TO DESTROY THEIR
PHONES.
THEY MAY CALL THAT SARCASM OR
POETIC LICENSE, BUT WORDS ARE
WORDS.
SEAN HANNITY LIVES OFF OF HIS
WORDS AND WE ALL KNOW THEY HAVE
A HUGE IMPACT.
IF ANYONE ACTUALLY DOES WHAT
SEAN HANNITY SAYS THEY ARE, THEY
WOULD BE COMMITTING A CRIME.
>> WHAT SEAN HANNITY ADMITTED TO
WAS, AND ENTICING PEOPLE TO DO,
IT WAS DESTROY EVIDENCE WHICH IS
A VIOLATION OF THE WITNESS
TAMPERING STATUTE.
>> NO RESPONSIBLE PERSON ON
TELEVISION, NO RESPONSIBLE
SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS SHOULD BE
ADVOCATING FOR PEOPLE TO DESTROY
EVIDENCE IN A SERIOUS FEDERAL
INVESTIGATION.
I DON'T THINK THAT WE WILL SEE
HIM PROSECUTED.
A FEDERAL PROSECUTORS GIVE
PEOPLE A VERY WIDE BERTH ON
FIRST AMENDMENT RELATED CONDUCT,
SO UNLESS THERE IS SOMETHING
MORE SPECIFIC TO LINK IT UP,
THIS WILL BE WHAT WE OFTEN
CATEGORIZE AS AWFUL BUT LAWFUL
CONDUCT.
>> IF HE WAS OUT THERE
ADVOCATING FOR MOLAR WITNESSES,
MAYBE THE MUELLER SHOULD SPEAK
TO HIM.
>> KNOWING MUELLER, I DON'T
THINK HE WILL LIGHT THAT FIRE
UNDER SOMEONE WHO GETS FREE
AIRTIME EVERY DAY.
BUT ONE ANGLE WOULD BE TO SAY,
I'M GOING TO A JUDGE AND I'M
GOING TO HAVE YOU CEASE AND
DESIST THIS ACTIVITY ON NATIONAL
TELEVISION.
SECONDLY, I WANT TO TALK TO YOU
AND SEE IF TRUMP HAS GOTTEN THIS
IDEA FROM YOU OR VICE VERSA.
>> Sean: WORDS MATTER.
IF I DEVISE THEM?
AND BY THE WAY, IT'S REALLY
DUMB, IT'S NOT GOING TO WORK OUT
WELL FOR YOU.
THE GREAT IRONY IN ALL OF THIS
IS, THEY ARE MORE ANGRY THAT I
WAS BASICALLY SAYING THAT
HILLARY CLINTON DID IT ALL.
SHE DID EVERY BIT OF IT.
AND BY THE WAY, I LOVE THE IDEA.
I WOULD LIKE TO MEET ROBERT
MUELLER'S MARY BRAND.
I WOULD LIKE TO MEET THAT MAN
WHO PUT PEOPLE IN JAIL FOR A
YEAR TO BE OVERTURNED BY THE
FIFTH CIRCUIT THAT WAS
EXCORIATED BY JUDGES NOT ONCE
BUT TWICE AND COSTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE JOBS.
I HAVE QUESTIONS FOR HIM AND
JEANNIE RAY AND BOB MUELLER.
NOW, THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA WOULD
PUT ME UNDER INVESTIGATION AND
LOCK ME UP FOR MERELY
HIGHLIGHTING AND THEN OBVIOUSLY
SARCASTIC WAY THE DOUBLE
STANDARD AND WHAT I HAVE BEEN
POINTING OUT OUR TWO-TIER
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
IN THE SAME PEOPLE DON'T GET THE
FACT THAT HILLARY ACTUALLY DID
ALL OF THAT.
SHE WIPED AWAY, ACID WASHED HER
HARD DRIVE, DELETED EMAILS OR
SUBPOENAED, HAD AIDS SMASHING
PHONES WITH A HAMMER AND LIED
ABOUT ALL OF IT.
ARE YOU REALLY THAT DUMB?
TELL ME IT'S NOT TRUE.
YOU WOULD THINK THAT ONE UNDER
MUELLER'S PLAN WOULD BE ABLE TO
GET AWAY WITH THAT.
IF ROBERT MUELLER ASK FOR YOUR
PHONE, DON'T DO WHAT HILLARY
DID.
AS I SAID LAST NIGHT, A WARM AND
WELL FOR YOU.
YOU WON'T GET THE SAME
TREATMENT, WHICH WAS A POINT OF
IT.
NOW THE MEDIA, WHEN YOU THINK
THEY HAVE HIT A NEW LOW, THEY
JUST DIG AND DIG AND DIG.
ONE MORE NEWS STORY THAT THE
MEDIA HATES TO, THE PRESIDENT
GRANTED CLEMENCY.
THE WOMAN'S NAME WAS ALICE
JOHNSON, A GREAT-GRANDMOTHER AND
SENTENCED TO LIFE IN PRISON FOR
ONE NONVIOLENT DRUG CRIME.
20 SOME ODD YEARS IN JAIL.
HER FIRST DAY IN FREEDOM IN 20
YEARS, SHE THINKS THE PRESIDENT
AND MOMENTS AGO SHE SPOKE WITH
OUR OWN MARTHA MacCALLUM.
>> THE ONLY WAY THAT I WAS ABLE
TO MAKE IT THROUGH THAT TIME,
AND THIS IS THE TRUTH, IT WAS MY
FAITH IN GOD.
I KNEW THAT ONE DAY HE WAS GOING
TO BRING ME OUT AND I LIVE MY
LIFE WITH AN EYE TOWARD IT ONE
DAY WALKING OUT OF THOSE DOORS A
FREE WOMAN.
IN THE DAY I GOT THE NEWS THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP HAD TO GRANTED
MY CLEMENCY AND GIVEN ME A
SECOND CHANCE AT LIFE WAS THE
BEST DAY OF MY LIFE.
>> Sean: GOD BLESS YOU, WE